la france contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme sous cette banderole
plus de 30000 80000 ou deux cent mille
personnes selon les sources ont marché
ensemble
cet après midi dans les rues de paris
pour dire l'horreur quinze jours après
la découverte du corps du jeune ilan
halimi torturé à mort voyez ce reportage
de ces faits ni perez et bruno l'hiver
tout dans les rangs serrés ils parlent
d'une même voix contre la barbarie qui a
conduit à la mort dylan ceux qui ont
fait le déplacement cet après midi sont
en grande majorité de confession juive
solidarité clairement affichée d'une
communauté qui affirme être victime d'un
antisémitisme grandissant lentilles
suite à une profondeur depuis des
décennies et chaque fois qu'il ya
quelque chose
les juifs les juifs les fruits sont là
on appartient une communauté où on est
toujours excuses pour le malheur
au delà de la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme
ce sont surtout les valeurs de la
république que d'autres sont venus
défendre un réflexe citoyen qu'il juge
indispensable la barbarie le passage à
l'acte
le fait que des gens en arrivent à faire
ça aujourd'hui notre pays c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est incroyable et ça
peut arriver à n'importe qui il y a
il a aujourd'hui il à demain bien sûr
pour peut-être france faut même pier 1
imports l'horreur elle est inacceptable
de bain problème jusque là les problèmes
d'un jeune homme qui a été assassiné
après torturer rentable et ça c'est
quelque chose que tout être humain ne
peut pas accepter
on est dans un pays qui est une
démocratie il faut donc le doute ce pays
unanime cry for study
parmi ceux qui ont appelé à manifester
certaines associations de lutte contre
le racisme le rassemblement
d'aujourd'hui est aussi une nouvelle
occasion pour la france de se pencher
sur sa mixité culturelle
je trouve que la france est plein de
cultures et il faut qu'on partage qu'on
se soutiennent entre moi et je deviens
passé de soutien et ça tu me fais de la
peine
il me semble que le meurtrier à la
limite c'est d'être un fou ce monstre
froid suite et françaises pour montrer
qu'il est de nouveau mur champ de se
mobiliser et d'agir surtout pour faire
en sorte de militer pour le vivre
ensemble et de concert une société
respectueuse des uns et les autres au
delà de leurs différences
encadrés par un important dispositif
policier la manifestation s'est déroulée
dans le calme sans incident majeur à
signaler